Signed Sealed Delivered welcome back to
CBS morning's the holiday season is
almost here and that means the post
office faces huge pressure to get those
extra packages out on time they're going
on a hiring spree to avoid a repeat of
the disruptions we all faced at the
height of the pandemic but somehow
makers are questioning whether it'll be
enough Scott McFarland is at a post
office in Maryland Scott good morning so
how are they planning to keep up with
demand
and naked morning it's arriving quickly
one month from today is the deadline to
ensure packages arrive by December 25th
a new Congressional review is issuing
some warnings of possible nighttime
deliveries at your mailbox between now
and then staffing issues and backups too
at her clothing business in Los Angeles
Beau and Aloha says holiday mail
deliveries help keep her store afloat if
I don't have timely delivery it impacts
my business because my staff is working
harder my staff is working longer hours
and then myself as well the U.S Postal
Service says it's adding more package
processing machines it is trying to hire
approximately 28 000 seasonal workers to
prevent a holiday crush and delays we'll
hear from Postal Service officials but
testifying before a congressional panel
a representative of managers and post
Masters warns hiring won't be easy he
says recruitment efforts are already
sluggish Nationwide including in
California plus New England and the
Midwest in a tight labor market
postmasters that are short staffed in
many areas of the country are personally
delivering mail on some routes in order
to fulfill that mission
in some regions advertised vacancies get
no applicants a new Congressional
investigation also found recent
absenteeism problems at Postal Centers
in Chicago Philadelphia and Baltimore
exacerbating worker shortages if there's
an absenteeism problem what happens to
delivery or performance it slows down
everything and it affects obviously
reliability for customers we need to
make sure that postal service is
reliable and that people are on Deck
doing their jobs and Aloha is
encouraging her customers to shop early
we're starting to take our request for
packages for Christmas delivery we don't
want to wait and see so we want to be
proactive and guarantee those pieces to
get there well before the time that
they're needed
postal worker representatives say the
end result could be after dark even
nighttime deliveries at your mailbox
between now and the end of the holidays
in the meantime here are the deadlines
recommended by the postal service for
December 25th delivery first class mail
send it by December 17th priority mail
by the 19th and express mail by the 23rd
but David the advice Remains the Same
don't cut it too close if you don't have
to
good advice thank you Scott after dark
delivery signed me up and thanks to all
the mail men and women we appreciate
what you do